hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the speed chess championship
that was played yesterday
uh this is the final game of their match
maxima sherlock versus magnus carlsen
and in the five plus one section a maxim
took the lead then
in the uh three plus one section maxime
was also leading by a two-point margin
and now we entered the bullet section
where uh interestingly this is the last
game of the match and magnus has won
three of the previous games and now
magnus needs one more one more win
to get back into the match so uh if he's
able to do it then we
we have a match again if not then it's
maksim in the finals against hikaru
and as you can see hikaru already made
his prediction in an interview after
defeating wesley so
he said that certainly playing magnus
again will be fun and i'm looking
forward to it foreshadowing that magnus
will
win the semi-final so uh let's see what
happened
as this is uh quite the game so it's
again one plus one not
the actual bullet and for these fine
gentlemen that's like it's already said
that's infinite time
so maxime opens with the white pieces
and he goes for e4
we have g6 by magnus trying to mix it up
going for the modern defense
uh d4 bishop to g7 and now knight to c3
and
d6 so the the setup of the modern
defense also
known as the the robotic defense knights
the f3 by max team and now
a6 by magnus now with bishop to e3 and
now
b5 preparing to think at this slight
square bishop along this diagonal we
have bishop to d3
so just uh perfectly natural developing
moves such as
for example paul morphy would do uh
knights to d7 and now
castles by maxine and here magnus
strikes in the center
with c5 uh we have d captures on c5 and
now
there is one game in the database where
knight captures and c5 was played but
here
we have d captures on c5 and it's as of
movie 8
that we have a completely new game so
here uh we have
uh e5 uh just advancing the pawn in the
center not allowing black to push e5
himself
blocks the dark square bishop uh and now
makes room for black to use this
diagonal so this is a carlson's next
move bishop to b7
and now e6 and already it's quite a
dangerous position for magnus uh
he needs to do something about this if
he moves the knight then he allows e
captures on f7
so he captures on f6 and now comes
knights the g5
by maxime going after the spawn if you
allow this it's just game over because
the queen uh will
and the bishop will be under attack so
you're gonna lose material here
so magnus forced to give up his very
strong dark square bishop
with bishop captures you could also play
knight to f8 which is
uh kind of passive as you you kind of
don't want to bring your pieces back
into the defense so bishop captures on
c3
b captures and now queen to b6 defending
the
uh the e6 pawn with the queen so c4
not allowing magnus uh uh to make use of
this uh
position here as at some point you want
to move the queen to c6 you want to play
c5
c4 and so on so here knight to g to f6
magnus continues development
and now a4 with now a triple attack on
the b5 pawn so magnus needs to react to
this
uh you could capture magnus decides to
push b4 instead
and now queen to e2 developing the queen
and connect
connecting rooks knights to e5 by magnus
and now bishop to f4 opening up a double
attack on the knight here
and magnus just ignores it he goes queen
to c6 and
of course you could capture the knight
but if you did that then you'd
get queen captures on g2 checkmate so i
hope
none of you were considering that so
here maxim just blocks the queen bishop
attack with
f3 now there's not much point in keeping
the queen and bishop on this diagonal
and
now knight captures on d3 as the knight
was attacked twice we have c
captures fixing the pawn structure and
now bishop back to c8 magnus needs to
now uh figure out a way how to
defend this e6 pawn so he plays the uh
well uh usually it would be a passive
one bishop to c8 but since the bishop
wasn't doing all that much on this
diagonal it could actually
uh be a better position for the bishop
so
rook f the e1 adding a third attacker to
the e6 pawn and here magnus just goes h6
and here what magnus is doing is he's
offering the e6 pawn to go in straight
into an end game for example if
knight captures queen capture so we'd
have captures captures and captures
and then for example g5 or king to f7 uh
goes into an end game with both players
having uh two rooks and a piece and six
pawns
and a maxim not interested uh in uh you
know putting the
faith of the match in the hands of uh
his end game skill so he prefers to keep
it
complicated knights to h3 and now
g5 uh pushing back the bishop bishop to
e5 and now as the knight is pinned the
first
rook to f8 unpinning uh knight to f2 the
knight can now
come to e4 or g4 and now a5 by magnus
and here
striking in the center with d4 uh magnus
captures we have bishop captures and
now bishop to a6 so again bishop finds a
useful diagonal
with a double attack on the c4 pawn and
maxime just defends it rook
a to d1 and here magnus goes for rook to
d8
there's always uh there's always this
idea of going
g4 because uh well you definitely want
to open lines towards the white king but
magnus first goes to rook 8 to d8 puts
pressure on the bishop
and now again bishop captures rook
caltrans seems like a reasonable thing
to do but
it's as if maxine just wants to keep as
many pieces on the board he doesn't want
to
give magnus even the opportunity of
trading down and again after bishop to
a1
we have this option of g4 which is uh
constantly in the position but magnus
still ignores it he first placed king to
f7
wants to connect brooks to get his king
to safety and now
knights the d3 the threat of course is
knight to the e5 check which would win
the queen
so kink the g8 and the now again knight
to the e5 attacking carlson's queen
queen to c5 with check and king to h1
and now comes knight to h5
and it's a very complicated position
especially when you're low on time
magnus was much lower on time here
already
than maxime and it's very hard for white
to make
any mistakes here yes there are some
tricks in the position but it would
take like three really bad moves for
whites to
uh even make use of this i don't know we
could try like something like
queen f1 uh let's say rook to f4
with ideas of shifting rook to h4 and
then another silly move like rook c to
d1
let's say rook h4 and now let's say you
do something like rook capture 78 king
to h7
and now we we need another bad move uh
because queen to d3
just uh will will end the game quickly
so we need
uh something like knights the g4 for
example and then we could
deliver knights to g3 checkmate with the
queen covering g1
and the pawn being pinned here so there
are some tricks in the position but
they are uh incredibly difficult to pull
off
as a white's position is very very good
here so here
we have knight the g6 by maxine
attacking the rook putting pressure on
e7
of course queen captures on e6 again a
threat so rook to f7
uh defending against that and now queen
captures an e6
and now not a lot to do here for magnus
he offers a queen trade
and just trading queens would actually
be okay for black magnus would be very
happy playing this end game
however maxine goes for the absolute
strongest knight captures on e7
with check and now what do you do here
uh well
here uh we have queen captures ne8 with
check so
what would you play here uh feel free to
pause the video and
find a best best move for maxine while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the very
sneaky queen g6
check opening up an attack towards
carlson's queen
while also if rook to g7 attacking
maxime's queen you just pick up the free
knight
the queen is still under attack you have
to move it and you wrap a piece uh
enjoying a great position however maxime
did not go for this
as uh you know even though that's a
that's a better position and objectively
you are winning
in a bullet game where the time is
really low you don't want to keep too
many pieces on the board especially
queens
so here maxime just trades queen
captures an e7 with rook captures on e7
rook
captures and now knight the f4 by magnus
uh and here uh rook to a7 attacking the
bishop
and here uh magnus was already extremely
low on time yes you constantly get a one
second increment when you make a move
but that means you have to constantly be
making moves uh
you know faster than one second passes
so here magnus quickly grabbed the pawn
which makes sense as if you capture on
c4 then magnus delivers rook to d1
checkmate the king has nowhere to go but
maxime
is not to be tricked by such uh such
ideas maxim just captured the a5 pawn
created an a4 pawn for himself
and magnus was down to some three
seconds on the clock here
and even though there's still a lot of
play here there you know anything could
still happen
here uh with maxine being of course much
better uh but
here those three seconds elapsed and
magnus
lost the game so uh that was
really really intense stuff it was
really close as magnus won the previous
three games he needed this one but next
team just played a brilliant game uh
with the white pieces completely crushed
him
and uh there was just no way back so at
the end at the end the score was
13 to 11 and uh
that's uh just it so before i forget uh
here
uh are the here is the let me just check
if i have it yeah i do have it
here is the bracket for the finals there
you have it
uh nakamura will face mvl
sorry about that uh there we go nakamura
will face mvl
uh in the finals uh and uh it's gonna
happen today so we're gonna cover those
games as well it's gonna be pretty crazy
uh and yeah uh so not uh not much more
to be said about this uh like i said uh
hikaru uh didn't really predict well who
would win this as
it's actually maxim who won this but uh
sorry about that
[Music]
sorry it's not the mailman or the pizza
guy it's
actually yelena uh so real captures on
a5 ends the game and
uh yeah it was a pretty pretty crazy
stuff uh maxime went
into the bullet section with a two-point
margin lead and the magnus was unable to
catch up to this
even with winning the previous three
games so completely deserving win
against world champion in all-time form
it's magnus carlsen and we'll see how
maksim does in the finals
against hikaru nakamura so yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
john malpass praksha veerkar damian
yordanov uh peter gordon and scott meyer
for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world such as
the finals today uh thank you i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your weekend